european green deal is supported before
investment invests in the european
green day investment fund research
small and medium enterprises industries
and of course explained today we launched
the european green deal investment
found the european green
deal is designed to combat climate
change but  Of course also
to help people to cope with these big
changes
that are coming to us because we want to hand over our
planet worth living and viable to
our children and
grandchildren today we have
assumed this big
one that will cover a billion euros in a decade
it is there for that  he will invest
in
new skills that have to be acquired on the
labor market new
jobs but also in green technologies
clean procedures technologies that are co2
free and that do not
pollute our climate he will be
there for people in the
regions that  most
experiencing change new jobs in the new
can find work opportunities but of
course also science and
research of course
startups and small and medium-sized
enterprises will also benefit from this we
want the european green deal to be
our new growth
strategy for europe we are pioneers today we also
want to be pioneers tomorrow and
that is why the investments we
are making in this decade are
decisive for the future of europe